foreign
[Music]
did world leaders come up with a plan to
save our planet
and we head to Bogota to see how South
America is tackling the climate crisis
[Music]
and we send an FYI viewer to check the
big screen version of a top West End
show I'm here at the Red Carpet to meet
the Stars on Matilda the Musical
[Music]
foreign
and here we go and hydrogen burnoff
igniters initiate seven six five four
stage engine start
three two one booster's indignation
and liftoff of Artemis one we rise
together back to the moon and Beyond
finally after three attempts NASA's
Artemis won the most powerful space
rocket in history Blast Off on Coast To
The Moon its mission is to test the
technologies that will take astronauts
back to the surface of the Moon later
this decade meanwhile back on Earth
another big story you've probably seen a
lot recently is the World Cup which
kicks off in Qatar this month yeah and
our very own braid in the zinc guitar
and joins us now hi Brayden I know hey
Raiden so what is it like actually being
there yeah so the atmosphere is
brilliant air loads of people have been
rolling in and in fact I'm in front of
one of the stadiums now the EC Stadium
where one of the games will be taking
place extremely soon and in fact 1.5
million fans from all around the world
are expected to come here to Qatar for
the World Cup it's amazing well some
fans and players are being asked to
boycott the games and not attend them so
why is that yeah so lots of human rights
groups have been saying Qatar should
never be allowed to host the World Cup
the reason being is because they are
very strict Muslim Wars over here for
example same-sex relationships are
illegal and there have also been claims
that the people they brought here to
make the stadiums and the hotels have
been treated really badly so the Qatar
World Cup organizers have said that
everybody is welcome and that nobody
will be discriminated against now the
World Cup governing body FIFA have said
that football should not be dragged into
Political battles and hand out moral
lessons in response 10 European football
associations including England and Wales
have said that human rights are Global
and apply everywhere England will also
be wearing one Lavon bands in response
and in protest towards qatar's
anti-homosexuality laws and that's the
thing football can really bring people
together but also highlight major issues
like equality and human rights what do
you think England and Wales chances are
on the pitch yes of course I'm hoping
England will win you never know they
might bring it home well we'll soon find
out reading nice one thanks guys bye
well here at FYI we want to hear what
you think about issues that matter the
most so we asked an FYI News Club at
rain Hill High School in Liverpool
whether they thought it was right for
Qatar to host the World Cup I feel like
it is for to give like everyone like all
the countries a chance to hold the World
Cup I think it does get us thinking
about all these issues that are going on
in other countries but I do also feel
like
it's also making people feel isolated
from the World Cup I think that it's a
nice way for lots of people to learn
about different cultures and different
countries I don't think we should allow
Qatar to host the World Cup I think it's
very wrong that you're not allowed to be
gay and it's against the law but
nowadays it's about who throws the most
money and whoever has the most money
gets the whole step we need to try and
build Bridges with other countries and
like let them know that being gay is all
right
[Music]
for another world cup story but is this
fake or fact
it's a fact that the last time England
won the World Cup was in 1966 but is it
fact or fake that the World Cup trophy
went missing that year and was only
found Again by a dog
it's a fact four months before the 1966
tournament was due to begin the World
Cup trophy was stolen but it was later
found by pickles the dog and his owner
just in time for England to Win It
[Music]
so like us you may have heard in the
news that there have been celebrations
in Ukraine as Russia withdraws from a
big city so what's actually happening
well Russian troops have pulled out of
Curson this was the only major cranean
city to be captured by Russia following
the invasion in February here and it's
in an area that President Putin has
claimed is now a part of Russia so this
is a major setback in his plans to take
over the country but does this mean the
war's nearly over Ukraine's president
zielinski visited the city and is called
the withdrawal of Russian troops a
historic day in the conflict in a speech
to troops president zielinski said
Ukraine is now moving forward and he is
ready for peace at the beginning of the
of the end of the war however just a day
later Russia's launched missile attacks
in neighboring cities to Ukraine with
claims that one landed in Poland experts
say that this is a message from Russia
that the war in Ukraine is far from over
11 year old Yusuf from Leeds could be
high supposed
more than Professor Stephen Hawking and
he loves a Rubik's Cube
[Music]
so for the past two weeks world leaders
have been meeting in Egypt for court 27
a conference to decide how to tackle the
climate crisis but what has been decided
Well a lot of people have criticized the
conference as not much has actually been
agreed on but there is still hope some
countries that don't have much money
that rely on industries that pollute our
atmosphores global warming gases are
finally waking up to the climate crisis
take Colombia for example in the capital
Bogota there have been a lot of changes
to make the city Greener his Sarah an
environmentalist who lives there with
more
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there is so much traffic here the city
is very overcrowded
so it's no wonder that Bogota is best
known for being one of the most polluted
cities on the Earth
I know what a title
this is a problem here's the issue oil
is a fossil fuel we get from deep
underground it sees to make petrol and
diesel for transport
when that expanded in an engine it
releases gases to the exhaust pipe into
the atmosphere those gases chop the
Earth's heat causing global warming
which leads to climate change we're all
beginning to experience
[Music]
pollution can make really ill it can
damage our lungs when we breathe it in
relax foreign
is so bad here that there are monitoring
instruments all over the city collecting
data to see how much pollution there is
in the air
[Music]
this website gives live updates
114 is very warring because it is a very
high level of pollution where I am
but the biggest victim of this pollution
is planet Earth
[Applause]
this is my cousin Francisco we got so
angry about pollution we set up a
campaign group and Stage protests to
demand the government to do more
in 2021 some of us traveled to Glasgow
for cop 26. the last meeting of world
leaders to discuss climate change and we
staged a protest with Greta turnberg
just giving ourselves a voice to be
heard can help save our planet
[Music]
and our girlfriend it's listening now
in the last few years the authorities
have spent hundreds of millions of
pounds making Transportation the city
cleaner
and we got to say too the authorities
asked residents for their ideas at
meetings and surveys
[Music]
we also came forcast to take us across
the city we can now travel seven miles
without the need to drive or get a bus
across the city down below
we can also avoid dangerous areas where
there is crime
we are so clean the buses bogotana has
the second largest feat of electric
buses in the world
1485 of them
and we now have the longest network of
safety Lanes in Latin America and they
will keep making it longer until it
reaches 550 miles of cycle Lanes
[Music]
I am very happy because yes I think
we've made progress yes I think there is
a better future so hopefully the
government will support the city to be a
Greener City and that helps the
environment but it also helps us
thanks Sarah and for more amazing
climate change beating ideas check out
the sky kids documentary cop 27 six ways
to save the planet available right now
on sky kids and Via our webpage
first.news FYI
so FYI gets access to big stars or films
and dramas but with Christmas coming up
there are nodes coming to big and small
screens including Matilda the Musical
yeah an FYI viewer Kiana told us that
she loved the musical and wanted to know
what the film would be like so we got
her a press pass to the premiere to find
out
[Music]
just look at all the cameras and
everyone here it's packed
I've never seen like a celebrity or an
actor in my life I'm so excited to see
Emma Thompson everyone knows her and
she's like so famous
once upon a time there was a little girl
who was trapped the movie is a musical
about Matilda who is a young gifted and
extremely intelligent five and a half
year old girl who struggles with the
stupidity of her family get to bed you
little bookworm
in the film we find out that Matilda has
magical powers and her school is run by
a nasty head mistress called Miss
Trunchbull played by Emma Thompson
Matilda Wormwood
criminals like you
[Music]
[Music]
Landing a role in Matilda I wonder what
it was like working with Emma Thompson
unbelievable a dream come true she even
um brought ice cream truck just set one
day so we can all get ice cream it was
just a dream come true and I just felt
so grateful for all of the opportunities
Miss Trunchbull she's like really
horrible but why do you think she's
horrible they've become that because
they're protecting themselves from
something and it's usually something
that someone has been terrible to them
that's not an excuse to become terrible
and say well I had terrible things
happen to me but that's what happened
with punch related what comes across
even better on the big screen is
Matilda's special powers and her
incredible courage obviously Matilda can
move stuff with her mind but her
superpower I think is courage her having
loads of courage and being brave and
being able to stand up for herself even
though she's only Young
Matilda Matilda Wormwood
and the writers behind the film and the
musical so that Matilda has a powerful
message there was an attitude that kids
didn't matter as much and they should
shut up because now I think we listen to
kids and I think that's right we should
listen to people you know some of my
teachers are amazing I got Mr Keenan if
you're out there he was amazing what
superpower would you have I think I'd
like to know everything I'd like to be
like human Google
especially the ones that are my age and
if you love The Stage musical version
you will love this big thumbs up from me
thank you FYI
nice one Kiana and don't forget if you
want to report for FYI why not get your
teacher to set up an FYI News Club at
your school it's easy just head to our
webpage for details you will also find
lots of amazing reports there from FYI
like our conversations where we discuss
the big issues as it's anti-bullying
week why not check out our conversation
with victims of bullying to give advice
on how to deal with it it's also
available on Sky Kids On Demand
[Music]
preschool in the Hinds sent us this
amazing video which they made for Auntie
bullying week they hope it will remind
us to reach out speak up and be brave
see you next time bye
wanna say
[Music]
s
I just wanna see you I just wanna see
you just wanna see you I wanna see you
foreign